[Musica]
[Applauso]
368 3 10 2013
cosa ci dicono questi numeri ci
ricordano quel giorno 3 ottobre dalle 2
13 33 168 persone hanno perso la vita
davanti alla costa di lampedusa
quanti di voi si ricordano ci avevano
quasi fatte era quasi arrivato a
destinazione
da lì a pochi avrebbero a terra dopo
aver attraversato ognuno un lungo
castellato da sofferenza indicibile la
traversa del mediterraneo con la notte
arrivati in vista è stato il conigli ora
di log più belli che il creato ci abbia
regalato hanno pensato disegna la loro
posizione a terra danno fa cono coperta
presto
le fiamme si sono propagate sul ponte
dove erano stipate 300 forze 500 gli
inizi di inferno oggi capita spesso che
mentre ruote notizia telegiornale è a
cena con mia moglie i miei figli e parlo
con unicredit a 0 al lavoro o stai
facendo una centinaia telefonata che
servono per organizzare giornate della
memoria e ripenso
e allora nella mia mente si ferma un
nitido un pensiero un avvertimento su
quale barcone e poi uno di quelle barre
avrei poter essere io come allora io
invece posso vivere la mia vita e devo
ammetterlo
a volte mi pesa mi sento in colpa io ce
l'ho fatta sono sotto fortunato loro
sono morti annegati in un metro di
fondali molti nella barca si erano
riempì d'acqua nel estiva in cui gli
scafisti davvero rinchiuse come top come
topi e la domanda che mi pongo ma perché
io sono ancora qua e loro no
la mia storia e quelli quelli di persone
hanno molta tratti in comune
avevo 17 anni quando ho deciso le serre
mio paese per evitare quelle che si
chiamava servizio militare obbligatorio
sulla carta dura 18 mesi
in pratica il regime incappucciato da
signore che si chiama sia sa four chi
può ottenersi a vita
entra come soldato perché ti riconoscerà
verra in un conflitto a bassa intensità
che dura da anni
coli topia e diventa forse lavoro
il regime può decidere di farti lavorare
dove o come quando vuole soldato
stradine e triste meccanico spacca petra
operaio impiegato può fare che cerca e
vuole tenerti al completo a disposizione
dell'esercito che è lo stato pagato
nulla se va bene sottopagato per tutta
la vita sotto il gioco tutta la tua vita
a loro completa disposizione
se io oggi sono qua grasse il fatto è
creduto o crotone una vita diversa
grazie a mia madre che mi ha aiutato a
mandarmi lì per dare un futuro sicuro mi
ha aiutato a lasciar eritrea senza
sapere se sarei mai riuscito ad arrivare
vivo la probabilità di farcela
erano molte scarse ma non mi sono
fermato ho fatto migliaia e migliaia di
chilometri sono passate come un oggetto
da un trafficante essere umano all'altro
sono vissuto per mesi in carcere libici
dal sud al nord del paese
ho visto amici uomini donne conosciute
perfetti sconosciuti venire picchiate e
torture torturati stuprati senza una
briciola di peta li ho visti morire
sono stato picchiato torturato ho
rischiato di essere lasciato a morire il
deserto sono arrivato al punto da
la perdere regione in mare sono arrivati
in italia
quattro anni dopo dal giorno cui ero
partito dopo sette giorni mi viene
riconosciuto lo status di rifugiato ma
con il permesso giorno non avevo più il
diritto di vivere nel centro di
accoglienza
non sapevo dove andare cosa fare
avevo tanta tanta paura ma il pensiero
il sacrificio di mia madre mi dava
ancora di andare avanti di non
arrendermi
non potevo mollare così ho imparato
italiano
ho fatto tanti lavoro lavorato in
campagna ho raccolto le olive l'arancia
ho lavato dalla piatta di alberghi e
stato molto difficile integrarmi in
italia perché era tutto nuovo la lingua
di posti la cultura e la mentalità
avevo perso i miei punti di riferimento
non conosceva nessuno
non so familiare non solo amico che mi
poteva consolare quando son possa
mollare 6 ripenso a tutte le persone che
incontra todini vita tipo in 3 categoria
nella prima mette coloro che mi hanno
sfruttato sapendo che non devo difendere
come avveniva in libia nella seconda ci
sono quelle persone senza conoscermi
quando mi vedo che per la strada
scorrevano o mi guardavano male come se
fosse la mia faccia vacis allora paura e
non riuscivo a capire il motivo
nella terza categoria essere quelle
persone mi hanno aiutato mi hanno fatto
sentire a casa che sono so davvero
importante problema integrazione e
ricordo con molto affetto emozione la
mia insegnante italiane con le in
sicilia però arrivato da poco settimana
ha cercato di aiutarmi a trasmettermi
con qualcosa ma soprattutto alleggerire
le mie inflessioni siciliana però
accusato abbiamo acquisito quando è
sbarcato i 368 non hanno avuto la
fortuna di conoscere le mie insegnanti e
mia insegnante non hanno conosciuto
nessuno
qui in italia avrebbe potuto dar loro
una mano aiutarli sentire meno sole ea
provare integrarli a costruire qualcosa
di buono che oggi come me che oggi sono
un mediatore culturale perchè perchè
qualcuno mette la possibilità mediatore
deriva dal termine latino mediare e
indica con lui nel mezzo colui che cerca
di far avvicinare due mondi diversi
quella non è né la prima né l'ultima
strage in mare i naufraghi continuano a
susseguirsi ma in quel caso e il mare ci
aveva restituiti ai corpi delle vittime
mettendoci per la prima per la prima
volta sotto gli occhi le tragedie
silenziose che si consumano senza
nessuno sappia nulla
oggi quello che faccio io cerca dare
volti voce a chi non ce l'ha fatta ma
soprattutto dare dignità a quelli a
quelli che ci hanno fatti sono arrivati
quando spiego la legislazione italiana
in materia di immigrazione a un ragazzo
appena sbarcato cerca il roster o il suo
dovere suo diretto oppure la compagna in
costoro per far avere un documento è il
mio scopo sempre soltanto uno
a contribuire il concetto strato di
integrazione si traduce in realtà nel
dopo le stragi in mare ho fondato il
comitato 3 ottobre per far sì che
ricordi quei morti non andasse perduto
nel 2016 sono riuscito a far approvare
dal parlamento
la giornata della minore
dell'accoglienza creiamo un protocollo
d'intesa col ministero istruzione con lo
scopo di affrontare il tema
dell'immigrazione nelle scuola da allora
giro istituti di ogni ordine e grado
dalla sicilia al trentino raccontando la
mia storia discutendo con le ragazze
temi dell'immigrazione
ascoltando i loro dubbi per ospedaliero
domanda lo faccio
perché scusate perchè parli
perché parlano con loro li porterà
lampedusa dei ragazzi così capiscono che
dietro ogni immigrato che arriva in
italia è chiamato clandestino [ __ ] si
poteva nascondere qualcosa è in grado di
voler bene questo paese come faccio il
mio piccolo ogni volta nascono progetti
collaborazione e ogni 3 ottobre li porto
a lampedusa
lo faccio perché vediamo perché sappiano
perché toccano con mano cos'è uno sbarco
perché incrociano con gli occhi alle
persone hanno attraversato il mare
stipati in centinaia una barca che
poteva contenere appena una decina con
rischio colare a picco da un momento
all'altro perché si rendono conto che
arriva dall'altra sponda del
mediterraneo come ho fatto io
pos ed insieme a potenziale se messi in
condizione di farlo può dare una mano a
migliorare le cose
non è una potenziale pericolo come le
definito a fini elettorali da molti
politici da loro media qualcuno infrange
la legge e compiendo api e questo tipo
di narrazione ma la maggior parte
cercano di restituire lo spettacolo
ricevuto è per tutti questi motivi che
al 38 prete ogni anno li porto a
lampedusa gli stessi motivi che oggi
visto la condanna vuoi la mia storia per
mantenere vivo e ricordi con i morti è
di fare un modo le tragedie simili in
futuro non si ripetano
ma anche da sottolineare una differenza
sottile quasi impresa semplice di bile
dettata da un attimo del caso da
un'estate di paura dal panico causata da
una coperta le fiamme e è una differenza
che occorre tra le persone quasi 4 mente
che sbarcano sulla cosa italiana quei
368 quella notte al 3 ottobre trova
nella morte
che come me sarebbero stati felici di
voler bene a questo paese è di fare la
propria parte a contro dirlo a
mantenerlo un paese meraviglioso e
grazie
[Applauso]